here with reaction 2024 Republican
candidate for president Florida Governor
Ronda santis and Texas Congressman chip
Roy both live from Iowa you know
Governor Dan santis so you send these
illegal migrants from Florida to New
York City because you're told it's a
sanctuary Sanctuary City jurisdiction
and then the sanctuary mayor says we
can't provide
Sanctuary well that's exactly right I
mean I think the left got on this horse
because they were trying to oppose
everything Trump was doing back in 2016
who was pledging a border wall and
border security and so they tied
themselves up into saying that they
should just have an open border when
face with the realities of that whether
it's Martha's Vineyard whether it's New
York City whether it's Chicago Los
Angeles they want nothing to do with the
effects of an open border the fact of
the matter is you have major Democrats
in this country now acknowledging you
cannot have an open border you cannot
have 9 million people 8 million people
people come in in a three-year period we
don't know who they are they're imposing
burdens on society criminal aliens
fencing all the whole nine yards this is
probably and you've pointed out Biden's
doing very poorly but of all the things
he's done this may be the biggest
dereliction of Duty he has not satisfied
his oath of office as president of the
United States to keep this state country
safe there's no doubt about it you know
Congressman Roy your governor Governor
Abbott he also sent illegal migrants
from Texas around the country do you
think it it was the actions of Governor
Dan santis you're sitting by and
Governor Abbott that finally forced
Mayors like mayor Adams to call out the
federal government and saying you you're
not doing your
job yeah Kay I think that's right I mean
last September it was the actions of
governor desandis who I'm proud to be
sitting next to and Governor Abbott that
I think save the elections for House
Republicans I think we have a majority
in the house because of their leadership
and importantly what we're seeing at the
border right now with 300,000 Encounters
in November December is on track for
300,000 that's 10,000 a day for that
perspective Jay Johnson said a thousand
a day was a crisis under President Obama
this is exacting an enormous toll on
Texans I had six kids in the school
district in which my wife and my family
and I live six kids who died last year
from fentanyl poisoning Ranch is getting
overrun Texas dying from fental
poisoning Americans are feeling it
across the country and the fact is we
have a solution House Republicans pass
hr2 a strong border security Bill the
key is we need to force getting it
passed and force the president to sign
it and if he won't do it we need to an
elect a president who will actually sign
that into law unlike president Trump who
in 2018 was siding with Paul Ryan to try
to pass an amnesty first rather than
border security first bill which left us
with the situation we're facing right
now you know Governor Dan santis you're
both in Iowa you've made it to all 99
counties there in Iowa you're currently
in second place in the polls Governor uh
you're behind Donald Trump by 30 points
I understand not a single vote's been
cast you're reaction to the latest
polling well what we're doing Kaylee a a
caucus is different than a normal vote
in the sense of it's a process you got
to be there for a few hours so what we
do is we accumulate people that commit
to caucus for us we have tens of
thousands of people in the hopper we're
adding more every day we just finished a
great event with with with chip Roy
Governor Kim Reynolds who's endorsed me
my wife Casey uh we're bringing more
people onto the fold so that's how you
have to do it and I think that's why the
polling typically hasn't predicted the
results because it's trying to measure
something that's just different so going
all 99 counties is the right way to do
it showing up in these communities and
when you do that when they're able to
hear you and ask you questions that's
when they commit to caucus for you so
we're excited about uh where we are uh I
think we have a better head of steam
than the previous winners of the caucus
and I than for having people like chip
on board that are uh that are stirring
the pot out here for
us yeah
con as I understand yeah
yes yeah on the on the polling point
right look the polls are supposed to
reflect public opinion not shape it
that's the reality and what's going to
decide this election are the people on
the ground not polls the people in Iowa
that's the beauty of our process right
we're for principles not princes we
don't coronate anybody we don't let
polls decide it's the American people
through this process and the people of
Iowa who take it very seriously it's
awesome it's a great experience my kids
are out here they said Dad this is kind
of like a congressional race in other
words they thought it would be bigger
and they're like no you're out shaking
hands meeting with people the governor's
been to 99 counties he's absolutely
killing it outworking everybody uh being
out here in Iowa and that's the process
that will that will actually I think
send the right candidate to be the
Republican nominee and that's governor
danis and Congressman you're taking your
holiday break you're in Iowa Monday
Tuesday Wednesday from what I understand
what are you seeing on the ground as you
travel around with Governor D
santis well I'm seeing an enormous
amount of enthusiasm it's great to be
here uh you know we met with a great
group here as Republican women they're
the backbone of of the the Republican
activists out there we've got a great
tour over the next few days my friend
Thomas Massie was out here Saturday they
had some great events great enthusiasm
look people are thirsty for a new
generation a new vision looking forward
not looking backwards somebody who can
serve for eight years somebody who won
uh his election Florida by by an
enormous margin 1 a. half million votes
won 62% of Hispanic voters 50% of single
female voters they don't want an
election that's close where you're
counting ballots singular they want to
win by an overwhelming margin and take
their country back they're enthusiastic
for Governor Dan
sanis Governor DeSantis final question
for you I mean you've been there a ton
Iowa all over what's the number one
issue you're hearing from voters when
you travel
around well when we started the process
I would have said said economy clear one
border clear number two now I would say
economy is 1 a and border is 1B I think
people are seeing the effects of the
Border we just did a ride along with a
sheriff in a sheriff department in Wayne
County which is a rural County in Iowa
they are seeing impacts from the
narcotics that are coming in so every
Community has become a border Community
under Joe Biden you run into Angel
parents in all corners of this country
now who have lost kids to fentol and a
lot of times these are kids that are not
addicted to drugs maybe they took one
pill think it was something else it's
laced with fentol and they get poisoned
to death so we have tens of thousands of
deaths every year Joe Biden doesn't seem
to care about that the Elites in DC
don't seem to care about it and I think
when you talk to Ians as well as people
in New Hampshire and other early States
uh there's the sense that's accurate
that the people who are running this
government do not care about the people
that they were elected to serve we need
to change that and 2024 gives us an
opportunity to do
so Governor Dan santis Congressman Roy
thank you from Iowa and Merry Christmas
to you both hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else